i feel like now there's like
a lot of mexican artists who are coming
up where it's just like like that's the
thing their music is dope and they
happen to be mexican if that makes sense
yeah i mean as opposed to like back in
the day i feel like you yeah yeah that
you were complementalizing to a certain
genre of music right like
that was a [ __ ] that i was fighting for
10 years ago
you know what i'm saying 15 years ago
though you know like they know [ __ ] that
me and bash were fighting for like where
was i yeah cuz i feel like bash did a
good job you know being like dude i'm
just making bangers yeah and he and he
was you know i mean i mean he was making
radio [ __ ] he was making kiss fm type
music what they call it you know
whatever like [ __ ] that's like just
super pop and no matter if who it is
it's right yeah no matter the race it is
yeah
it's on but that was a [ __ ] that you
know i was fighting for 12 years ago
where it was like
when people you said like are you a
chicano rapper he's like nah i'm not i'm
just a rapper i'm just a rapper just the
rapper and and i was doing that type of
music i wasn't necessarily banging on my
music it was just i was just doing
good street music or you know [ __ ] that
was potentially going to be on the radio
you know what i'm saying so i wasn't
never aiming for anything like that and
then you know that goes the same with my
comedy you know i'm not doing comedy for
just chicanos either i do cater to it
you know what i'm saying but i don't
just specifically do it for them you
know i do it for whatever i think is
funny and that was the same thing with
music i wasn't doing this type of music
or that type of music i think what's
happening now with you know with all the
artists that are starting to pop that
are essentially latino descent which
like the little pumps and you know i'm
saying like
all these dudes like that's dope man
like that's the [ __ ] that we wanted to
do 12 years ago
and you and because of the culture
changing and because of social media
it's more acceptable to just be another
race and be able to get on like that you
know what i'm saying it's i don't think
little pumps the first one or you know i
mean the takashi's of the world or yeah
i mean i mean there's plenty latinos the
bad bunnies are taking over you know
what i'm saying like i mean it's it's
it's that kind of vibe i think the
industry in the world is starting to see
that the latino market
is the consumer and they buy records
facts and they follow it the fastest
growing
you know what i'm saying because we're
you know like we are the ones that
essentially buy the ticket when you're
up and we are the and we are the people
that i think it's when you're down when
you're down we go see you at the car
show we go see you at these places we
are the ones that support a lot of these
rappers that were hot 20 years ago
you know what i'm saying uh i host a lot
of the shows yeah you know what i'm
saying we the latino consumer is the one
that buys and i think you know once they
really grasp the situation you know
you know we're going to see an influx of
a lot of rappers even here from a later
gonna start to pop and not just one yeah
i mean you know what obviously we got
the king little g's we got the drummer
boys
there's a lot of dope artists you know
what i'm saying um
ruchi's
yeah yeah you know i mean like so
there's a lot of dope artists that are
waiting just to bubble you know what i'm
saying to get that one record that's
going to take them to the next level i
think all of them are just one record
away you know what i'm saying one record
away you know what i mean obviously
someone's like already such an error
like like like peso
swa like there's so many dope young
mexican rappers that are like
bubbling baby young and there's just
tons of them yeah yeah there's so many
of them though there's such a crazy
movement going on right now it's still
to see and they're starting to see that
yo we really support this [ __ ] we buy
this [ __ ]
and
you know i mean hopefully it gets bigger
than what it is now